si de momento hay 13 personas salidas
que ya han sido llevadas al hospital de
la ciudad una de ellas al parecer se
encuentra en estado crítico cinco de
ellas habrían recibido un impacto de
bala de momento la policía continúa
investigando porque se han encontrado
también artefactos sin activar en la
estación de metro el sospechoso al
parecer es un hombre de mediana edad que
vestía un chaleco de color naranja y una
máscara de gas fuentes cercanas a la
investigación han revelado de manera
anónima que al parecer este hombre
habría comenzado a disparar contra
varios vagabundos que se encontraban en
uno de los vagones de este metro a
continuación ha pasado a otro vagón y ha
seguido disparando de momento no se ha
dado más información sobre el sospechoso
sospechoso tampoco se ha confirmado si
ya ha sido detenido la policía como digo
está investigando los hechos que han
ocurrido a primera hora de esta mañana a
las 8 de la mañana varios transeúntes
llamaban a la unidad de bomberos porque
veían salir humo de uno de los vagones